i think we're beginning to uncover this
empirical disagreement about what it is
that's good for the individual and what
it is that makes them happy and i'll go
back to something i raised um uh i i
raised in the debate which is uh this uh
this theory of durkheim that now has
been uh uh popularized by
uh by jordan peterson but um
durkheim argues that
um that
the
uh he's writing a book on suicide he's
trying to understand what what brings
individuals to suicide and he coins this
term anomi
lack of law
and the argument is that
uh that
individuals
basically
are
healthy and happy
when they find their place in
in a hierarchy within a loyalty group in
a certain place in a hierarchy
they compete and struggle in order to
rise in the hierarchy but they know
where they are they know who they are
the kids today like to say they know
what their identity is
because they associate themselves
their self expands to take on you know
the leadership the different layers the
past and the future of this this
particular hierarchy and i completely
agree with iran that some of these
hierarchies are are pernicious and
oppressive
and and terrible and some of them are
better
what we might disagree about is that
that you can find um human beings who
are are capable of uh becoming healthy
and happy
off by themselves without participating
in in in this kind of structure the
minute that you accept if you accept
that this is empirical reality but human
beings it it's an it it's an iron law
you can't you you can't do anything you
you can tell you human beings that they
can be free of all constraints all you
want and you can get them to do
things that that as you say dissolve
dissolve their pla they can have
contempt for hierarchies they can say
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna serve the
man i'm gonna you know i i'm just going
to burn them all down you can you can
get them to say all get kids to say all
these things you can get them either to
be marxists who are who are
actively trying to overthrow and destroy
the existing hierarchies or you can make
them some kind of liberal where they
basically pretend the hierarchies don't
exist they just act like that that
they're not there
in both cases and it's not coincidence
that that's what universities teach is
your choice is either marxist revolution
or liberal ignoring of the hierarchies
in both cases what you've done is you've
eliminated the possibility
that the young person will be able to
find his or her
place in a way that allows them to grow
and exercise their their their their
love their drive their their creativity
in order to to advance something
constructive you've eliminated it and
you've
put the burden on them
you know kind of a niche burden to uh to
just be the fountain of all values
yourself
which you know maybe some people can do
it
but almost no one can do it and i think
that's empirically true and so i i think
by telling them
about their freedom rather than telling
them about how
about the the need to join into some
some
uh traditionalist hierarchy that can be
good and healthy for them
i think we're destroying them i think
we're destroying this generation and the
last one and the next euron is the
burden of freedom destroying mankind
what freedom i mean uh
how many people are indeed free the the
look the problem is that we we were
caught up on political concepts
and we we've
we're moving into uh
ethical issues and and
i i don't think it's right to tell
people
you're free go do whatever the hell you
want
just just use your emotions you know
just just go where you want to go
you know in the spur of the moment think
short term don't think long term or
don't think why think
one has to provide moral guidance and
and morality here is crucial and
crucially important
and part of taking responsibility for
your own life is establishing a moral
framework
for your life and and what does it mean
to live a good life i mean that's much
more important in a sense
of a question and it is
it is my belief that people can do that
they can find and choose
uh the values necessary to achieve a
good life but they need guidance they
need guidance this is why religion
evolved in my view because people need
guidance so so so that says you know i
had called religion a primitive
philosophy it was the original
philosophy that provided people with
some guidance about what to do and what
not to do and
secular philosophy is supposed to do the
same and the problem is
that i think religion and
99 of secular philosophy give people bad
advice about what to do and therefore
they do bad stuff and and uh some of
that sometimes
uh you know because uh uh when they do
good stuff it gets reinforced that we
survive in spite of that but uh ideas
like content hegel and and marks and so
on give young people awful advice about
how to live and what to do and as a
consequence really bad stuff happens and
the world in which we exist today which
we agree
there's a lot of
pathologies to it a lot of bad stuff
going on in my views going the wrong way
in my view are products
of of of a set of ideas uh you know on
the one hand i think i think uh
christian ideas on the other hand i
think secular philosophical ideas that
have driven this country and the world
more generally in a really really bad
direction and this is why the this is
why what i do what i do because i think
at the core of it the only way to change
it
is not to impose a new set of ideas from
the top because i worry about who's
going to be doing the imposition plus i
don't believe you can you can force
people to be good
it's to challenge the ideas it's the
question the ideas it's to present an
alternative view of morality an
alternative a set of moral principles an
alternative ultimately an alternative
view of political principles but it has
to start with morality if you don't and
and my morality centered on the
individual and what the individual
should do with this life in order to
attain a good life uh i i believe that
leads to happiness but but but the good
life
that's why it's good right the the the
goal is survival and thriving and
flourishing and and happiness ultimately
uh but politics is a servant of that in
the end it's it's not an end in itself
so the real issue is
you know you ask before what is the
value relationship
there's enormous value in relationship
because we get values from other people
we don't produce all our values we don't
produce all our spiritual values and we
don't produce all the material values
other people on a massive
benefit to us because they produce
values we can't there's a massive
division of labor in terms of values not
just in economics but also in philosophy
and elsewhere it's why we have teachers
it's why we have moral teachers small
teachers are important to help guide us
towards a good life not all of us are
philosophers but what i do
demand if you all of individuals this is
where i put a burden on people right
understand what you're doing
right
you know don't embrace a moral teaching
because it was tradition don't embrace
them all teaching because your parents
embrace that don't embrace them all
teaching just because your teachers are
teaching it
challenge it think about it embrace it
because you
embrace it you might be wrong you might
embrace the wrong one but take moral
responsibility take responsibility over
your life by
evaluating testing challenging
what you have received and choosing
what your
what what you're going to pursue and i i
acknowledge empirically that most people
don't do that
and uh and and and this is why
intellectual leadership is so important
uh this is why you want to get p
you want the voices in a culture to be
good voices so that those people who
don't think for themselves
land up being followers but they end up
being followers of somebody good versus
followers of somebody bad
but
for the thinkers in the world out there
who i think are the people who count who
the people who shape society
no no
not not count in a sense that you can
dismiss the lives of others and you know
because i'm you know obviously i'm
anticipation and antibiotics
but
yes
i don't want to sound like plato but in
a sense that they're the ones who shape
who land of shaping the world they're
the ones who land up shaping how how
they will be
i want those people to make choices
about their values and not to just
accept them based on traditional base
the commandment or based on
where they happen to grow up
you